chin straps get their name from that
black marking that runs under their chin
uh and they're also sometimes called
stone breaker penguins because of that
ear piercing screech
they're really sociable birds that
waddle ashore in these massive numbers
to nest
over a million breeding pairs have been
recorded
in a single colony they go to pretty
extreme lengths to climb up and make a
nest with a view
there is a lot of penguins here
every ridge we've got in every little
corner we've gone around
there's just more and more chinstrap
penguins
and there must be
tens of thousands of birds here
it just goes to show how much food there
must be in that ocean to support all of
these mouths
well there's no food for the penguins on
land so every morning they line up like
thousands of commuters at rush hour to
hit the water
it's an amazing scene so i'm going to
set up down at the shoreline
but we do need to keep an eye out for
the other locals
so with no natural predators on land
and almost no human contact
these antarctic fur seals have never
developed a fear of people okay okay hey
that's close enough go on no keep going
so these are the naughty ones wait back
up
you just gotta uh yeah remind
that we're not a chew toy
keep going
there we go and they're usually
pretty obedient
epic adventures with bertie gregory a
disney plus day premiere september 8th
on disney plus